حياته مع رفيده ياسين على العربيه
واليوم رحله الى عالم عربي مختلف زاخر
بالثقافات والعادات والتقاليد سنتعرف سويا
على قبيله ثقافته ضاربه جذوره في الاعماق
وهي حياه المهريين في اليمن
بتنفرد محافظه المهره في شرق اليمن على
الحدود مع سلطنه عمان بموروس شعبي مختلف
ومستقل عن باقي الموروثات في الجزيره
العربيه بشكل عام وتختلف عن جميع انحاء
اليمن يعني يمكن يطلق عليها يمن مصغر
مختلف بتوصف المهره والمهريين بانها
البوابه الشرقيه لليمن فهي بتطل على بحر
العرب وتمتد شرقا حتى الحدود الدوليه مع
عمان
شمالا حتى صحراء الربع الخالي وغربا حتى
وادي المسيله في حضرموت
الموروث الشعبي المهري له صفات ومميزات قد
لا يفهما الا المجتمع المحلي نفسه قد لا
تكون متعارف عليها في بقيه انحاء اليمن مش
فقط في الخارج
الخصوصيه الفريده دي بتتعلق بالتراث
للمهريين العريق وخاصه في الاعراس المجتمع
الخاص بالمهريين عنده عاداتته وتقاليد
وتقوس الخاصه تحديدا عند العروس المهريه
حفلات الزواج عند المهريين ما بتكون
تفاصيله مدربه مناسبه عابره بل بتتم على
مراحل ولابد من اكتمال هذه المراحل
للاعتراف بالزيجه او للاحتفاء بها داخل
المجتمع
مرحله الزواج بتبدا كما هو معروف متعارف
عليه بذهاب الشعب مستحب عدد من افراد
اسرته الى اهل الفتاه عشان يطلب يدها وقد
يكون دمبني على حب واعجاب او قد يكون
اختيار تم من قبل اسرته او احدى الوالدين
وده عشان يتقدم لخطبه او للزواج منها يطلق
على الخطوه اللي ابتلي الخطوبه اسم السدود
وفيها بيعقد اهل الخطيب والخطيبه لقاء
مشترك بيتم فيه تحديد المهره والمهر ده
بيتم على حسب امكانيات الاسره وبيتم
التفاخر به داخل المجتمع وكل ما زاد جمال
الفتاه داخل قبيله المهريين كلما زاد
مهرها وبيختلف المهر من منطقه لاخرى على
حسب العذاب طبعا في نفس اللقاء ده بيتم ما
يسمى قبضه وهو انه للزوج بيقدموا قبل اهل
الزوجه لابنتهم عباره عن خاتم بيسمى
مرتجيت الخاتم ده بيدري تقديمه غالبا او
يتم استبداله بمبلغ معين لاهل الفتاه
والخاتم ده نادر جدا وبيتم توارثه من
الجدات خلال الاسر المختلفه
بعد تقديم الخاتم ده بتدخل خطوه جفن اي
انه الفتاه من الليله ديك بتبدا بالاحتجاب
وما بتطلع من بيته الا في يوم الزفاف مهما
طالت مده الخطبه وكذلك صديقاته قريباته
واهلها بيتم تجمع الفتيات واداء الرقصات
المختلفه
وبيقوم باعطاء الطعام للفتاه لتسمينه لكي
يزيد وزنها قبل اتمام الزوجه
بعد انتهاء مرحله السدود المهمه جدا عند
المهريين في الزواج بتتم عدد من الخطوات
بتاتي بعدها بيوم واحد فقط مرحله اسمها
جرير وبيكون ده بعد السدود غالبا بيوم
واحد فقط
المهجريت عباره عن بعض الاشياء
والاحتياجات اللي بيقدم الخطيب لاهل
خطيبته وغالبا ما تكون الملابس وتكون
بحتياجات مختلفه بتهديها الفتاه للقريبات
وجيراننا وصديقاته بعض الاحتياجات الخاصه
الاخرى قد يوفر العريس عند اتمام هذه
الخطوه لاهل الفتاه او لعروسه
المرحله الثانيه المهمه جدا بتتعلق
بالزفاف وبتدري من خلاله خطوتين هي زواج
الرجال وزواج النساء بتقام حفلتين في كل
من الاسرتين بطريقه مختلفه وفي طقس مختلف
تتنوع انواع واوقات الزفاف عند الرجال
منهم اللي بيحدد انه يكون في الصباح الى
المغرب والبعض الاخر بيفضل انه يكون في
ساعات الليل وفي كلتا الفترتين بتكون
المراسيم والعادات والتقاليد وحده بس
بيختلف التوقيت مراسيم الزفاف بتبدا
وفيها بترحب قبيله الزوجه بالضيوف
وتستقبلهم اثناء قدوم كل قبيله بشاعره او
باحد الشعراء من ابناءه
تحيه زياره القبائل الاخرى بتكون عبره
ترديد اشعار او اغنياتهم للاحتفاء بقدوم
او بمشاركتهم لهذه المناسبه وهم بيرفعوا
الدندن وده شعر المهريين بيتم
استقبالهم وترحيبهم بالشعر المهني وبتستمر
فتره الدندان حوالي ساعتين تقريبا بيتم
فيها تناول القضايا العامه والمدح بالشعر
المهري
وحتى يومنا هذا بيتم تداول هذه العاده في
كل حفل زفاف ايا كانت خلفيه الاسره داخل
المجتمع بس الحفاظ على العادات والتقاليد
من الطقوس التي لا يمكن التنازل عنها ابدا
الخطوه الثانيه بتبدا بعقد القران بعد
انتهاء الدندنه وفيها بيجري تقديم البسط
وده عباره عن عصير بعده بتقدم القهوه
والشاي على الطريقه اليمنيه التقليديه
واذا بيكون بعد استراحه قصيره للضيوف
وبتبدا بعد ذلك مراسم عقد القران بحضور
العريس واهل العروسه بحضور قاضي بيعقد
القران بينهم وبيعلنوا زوج وزوجه خلال
الاهازيج الشعبيه دي بعد اعلان عقد القران
بتقدم وجبه الغداء اللي بتكون عباره عن
ارز ولحضاء
ضخمه بتقام فيها الولائم للتعبير عن الكرم
والجود الخاص بثقافه المهريين مراسم
الزفاف في اوساط النساء الخاصه بالمهره هي
الاخرى بتتميز بعادات وتقاليد منفرده
وبتمر بمراحل عندها علاقه بما يسمى
بالفوله او الفواله او الوجبه وبتاتي فيها
النساء من جميع انحاء المنطقه للمشاركه في
الزفاف ولرؤيه العروس وبعد اكتمال عدد
الحضارات بتقدم لهن الفواله وهي عباره عن
حلوى وقهوه وعصائر
وطبيعه هذا المجتمع في اكرام الضيف وفقا
لثقافته وده بيكون خلال الحفل
لهذه الزوجه
في مرحله اخرى بتسمى بالشرح بتبدا فور
الانتهاء من الفواله وفيها بتدق الطبول
وتقام الاغنيات وبتبدا المغنيات الشعبيات
بتغني ويتم الرقص فيها بزي محدد وهو يرمز
لقبيله المهرين وعلى هذا النحو بينتهي
الشرح تفاصيل عديده ومراحل مختلفه بتاتي
بعدها مرحله ثالثه تسمى بالمجلي هي اخر
مراحل الزفاف عند المهريين وده بيكون عبر
ايام مختلفه
بتم في هذه المرحله تقديم الزوجه للحضور
للمشاهدته وتقدم لها الهدايا او الطرح من
اهل العريس وهي عباره عن هدايا من اهل
الزوج بتشمل ذهب وهدايا اخرى متنوعه حسب
استطاع العريس واسرته ومكان ومكانتهم داخل
قبيله المهرين
بعد الانتهاء من المجالي بتقوم الحضارات
بصحاب الزوجه الى غرفه زوجها من المفارقات
العجيبه جدا عند قبيله المهريين ان الزوج
بيبني غرفه للعروس في بيت اهلها
وبيقيموا في بيت اهل الزوجه في غالب
الاحيان ان لم يكن الزوج قد بنى بيتا
منفصلا وذري تكريمه وتعزيزه ولابقاء قريبه
من بيئته ومن حضن اسرته حتى بعد انتقاله
من حياه العزوبيه الى الحياه الزوجيه
المراه عند قبيله المهريين عندها مكان
ومكانه
وبتتمتع بقوه داخل منزله وصوتها مسموعه
رغم انه العادات والتقاليد بتفرض خطوه
الرجل داخل القبيله بس لما بيتم على حساب
قهر المراه اللي عندها دور كبير في الاسره
وتقوم بتقديمه في ادوار مختلفه لا تقتصر
فقط على الاعباء المنزليه خاصه انه ابعاد
الفتاه عن اسرته بعد الزواج بيكون واحده
من الاشياء اللي قد ترفضها او تتشائم منها
بعض الاسر لانهم لم يعتادوا على فراق
اسرهم طيله السنوات اللي مضت وبيستمر ده
حتى تتيسر الحاله الماديه
للزوج ويقام بيت منفصل بتنفيه والحياه
بعيدا عن الاسره الصغيره المهريين هم
قبيله داخل اليمن ولكن عندهم لغه خاصه
وثقافه خاصه وعادات وتقاليد مختلفه قد
تجعل منهم مجتمع مختلف داخل الدوله
الواحده وكذلك هم بيحرسوا جدا على احياء
والحفاظ على عادات وتقاليد من الاندثار
بيقام اي محاوله لطمس هويتهم المفتخروا
بها بشكل كبير حتى انها بتكون مدونه في
شعرهم واغنياتهم اللي بيقوموا بالتباهي
والاعتزاز بها بين القبائل الاخرى ببساطه
لان هذه هي حياتهم
[موسيقى]